in this lesson we're going to talk about
multiplying matrices so what is a matrix
how do you multiply matrices we're going
to get into all that in this lesson
first of all what a matrix is it's a way
of arranging data or organizing data
instead of like a a list you're making
it more like into a table or a chart
okay it's called a matrix and all these
quantities are called elements but the
main thing you want to know about a
matrix are
you know how many rows does it have and
how many columns does it have so first
of all the rows they go this way
horizontally and the columns they go
vertically like this so this matrix here
has one two rows
and it has one two three columns columns
like the roman columns columns on a
building so it's a two by three matrix
so you always want to do rows first and
column second so for this matrix it has
one two three rows
and one column right so three by one and
this one has one two rows and two
columns this is actually called a square
matrix because it's square squared has
the same number of rows as columns but
when you multiply matrices you always
want to multiply
the matrices in such a way that see this
is rows by columns for the first matrix
rows by columns for the second matrix
you want to make sure that these inner
dimensions that they match that they're
the same otherwise the matrices are
incompatible you can't multiply them
together you're not going to it's not
going to work just not possible and then
what you end up with is you end up with
these two quantities here at the end the
number of rows here and the number of
columns here so for example if you have
a three by two matrix times a two by one
matrix this matrix multiplication is
possible these inner dimensions match
and you're going to end up with a three
by one matrix so that's going to be the
resultant size of your matrix it's going
to have three rows
okay like this
and one column so let's go through an
example see if you can pause the video
and do this one on your own we'll go
through it together so here it says what
is a times b so here's our matrix a
here's our matrix b first thing we want
to do is we want to make sure that
they're compatible so we have a two by
three
and a three by one so the inner
dimensions match we're going to end up
with a two by one two rows
okay and one column so this is two rows
this way and one column vertically
okay so the next thing we're going to do
is we're going to multiply the row
times the columns we're going to take
this first row times the first column so
if we do that we get
1 times 1 which is 1
plus 3 times 2 which is
6 plus 2 times 6 which is 12. if we add
those together we get 19.
now if we take the
second row times the second column and
by the way when you do this sometimes
it's helpful to
go ahead and work backwards you say well
what position is this in it's in the
second row
first column so you always do rows by
column so second row first column that
tells you to take the second row times
the first column and what i think about
doing is i think about taking this row
and rotating it like this so that the
first element in the row matches up with
the first element the column second
element in the row second with the
column third or third so it's like this
you're rotating and the ones that match
up you're multiplying and then you add
them together so in this case zero times
one is
zero plus negative one times two is
negative 2 plus 5 times 6 is 30 and if
you add those together you can see
you're getting 28
so this is our resultant matrix right
here now you can see if we tried to
multiply like matrix b and c we would
have an issue because these inner
dimensions they don't match see one and
two so that's just not going to be
possible so that's how you do matrix
multiplication i'll see you in the next
lesson